حسنًا ، أعتقد أنني سأفعل وداعًا ،
إنها نقطة الالتقاء الرئيسية في
المنطقة للمجتمع الفني الدولي بأكمله ،
إنها مشهد فني متطور ومثل
مشهد فني سريع الحركة ، أعني أن هناك
أشخاصًا وفنانين دوليين يأتون
من جميع أنحاء العالم يمرون
عبر هذا المكان
أعتقد أن الفنانين الكاملين يحفزون
[الموسيقى] ،
إنه ليس نوعًا من المشاريع الأوروبية التي تركز
بشكل أساسي على
الإنتاج الفني في أوروبا وأمريكا الشمالية ،
وهو ما يسمى في هذه
الأيام بالجنوب العالمي ، لذلك نحن نتطلع إلى
أمريكا اللاتينية  أفريقيا جنوب آسيا والشرق
الأوسط وآسيا الوسطى هي دبي بها خمسة
أقسام
حديثة من المقيمين في مشاريع bah-bah-bah المنفردة
وأوينو ،
اسمي علي شاه دا دا كونا ، نحن في
الخارج للشراء في قسم يسمى المقيمون
، لقد دُعيت للمشاركة  في هذا
القسم من المعرض ، لكي تكون جزءًا من هذه
المجموعة من فناني أمريكا اللاتينية
لتقديم عروض تقديمية فردية ، فإن العمل الذي قمت
بإنشائه لهذا الموقف هو عبارة عن
مجموعة من الأعمال الجديدة تسمى Aff  airs
وهي مصنوعة من مناشف الشاطئ التي عليها
أعلام وطنية مطبوعة على
دولارات الشاطئ ، لقد كانت المرة الأولى التي أزور فيها دبي ،
لذا لدي فكرة عن دبي باعتبارها
المكان الذي يأتي فيه الأشخاص من أي
مكان وأيضًا علم الجنسيات ثم
فكرة جديدة  كان المكان في
ذهني إلى حد كبير لأول مرة لدينا
الآن وهو قسم مخصص
لجميع المشاريع الشعبية في الدولة من
قبل الشباب ، ويتواجد 15 في أبو
ظبي وقد بدأنا للتو
منذ عام ونحن  شخصيًا لم أكن أعرف
عدد المجموعات الفنية التي كانت موجودة ،
فهناك الكثير من الفرص ، هناك
متسع كبير لنا لمعرفة المزيد سواء كان
ذلك من مؤسسات مثل متحف اللوفر
أو مؤسسات مثل
شارع سيركل أفينيو الذي نحاول حقًا
وضع مشروع  والثالث الذي
يتجاوز قليلاً ما نفهمه جميعًا
أن هناك
عينًا معينة سيتم تطويرها
في المستقبل لمناقشة
عمل فنانينا مع مجموعات محددة ومع
أماكننا المحددة لبناء المشاريع
التي تدور حول كيفية تواصلنا حول كيفية
ربطنا
بينكما